hello everyone sorry about not posting
any videos for the past two days I was
enjoying the creations he said with my
girlfriend and that being said the next
game i prepared for you was played in
2012 in the washington international
tournament and it's played between a
wonderly and and the Larry Kaufman now I
wonder league is a well he's definitely
a prodigy and he broke a whole lot of
world records he was the first person to
ever achieve the ratings 2000 in the
world
he was the first the youngest person
ever to defeat an international master
he was the youngest person to ever
defeat a grandmaster and he broke a
whole lot of record set for the USA area
and this next game I'm I'm going to show
you is the game where he defeated the
Grand Master Larry Kaufman when he was 9
years old so let's see this game how
does a nine-year-old be the Grandmaster
a wonder link is the white and the cuff
one is black so we have e for bi Liang
'if I've Knight to f3 knight c6 d for
the scotch ECAD person d4 Knight
captures on d4 and now Knight to f6 the
popular schmitz variation so we have
Knight captures on c6 b captures on c6
and now II five by being Queen to e7 we
have a queen to e2 and now Knight to d5
we have a c4 and in this position a cup
one place at night to b6 but it's also
possible to play a Bishop to a6 if you
remember a couple of days ago I posted
the game Gary Kasparov versus Worsley so
and what this all went for this Bishop
to a6 variation but come from play
Knight to be 6 so we have night 2 B 2 a
5 and now community for this is a very
nice centralizing move by lien and black
can play something like d5 here for
example if he wants to you know exchange
some pawns and this would probably lead
to an equal equal position but Kaufman
decides to play g6 and develop the
bishop - sharing it so we have g6
the Bishop to d3 now Bishop to g7 Knight
to f3 defending that e5 pawn and now
Queen to b4 check and now well if I was
playing white here I'd probably go for
Bishop to d2 you know just given up this
be porn and prepare prepare prepare to
castle and then go for rook to be one
and you know things like that which
probably come from one Kaufman went for
but Leon decided to play Knight back to
d2 to defend like this and keep this
pawn on b2 so we have castles castles
and now Rock te8 and now Knight back to
f3
so this Knight kind of went from f3 to D
2 to s 3 so a lot of tempos for that
night but the position seems okay so cop
1 plays d5 and we have Queen to h4 and
here come on come on winds the winds the
phone here he plays Knight captures on
c4
we have Bishop captures on c4 and Queen
captures in c4 and although it seems a
common is up upon now and it says like
Callie and can capture she is Queen now
and the triple his pawns but this
wouldn't actually be such a big
disadvantage for black as he does have
the bishop pair so after after someone
was like Bishop to a5 and rook to b8
black would be black would be better
here so after Queen captures on c4 Liam
plays a bishop to that for preserving
the Queen's on the board and while
preparing some sort of an attack on the
King side we have Bishop to d7 rook a to
C 1 Queen to b4 and now a3 offering to
give up this B to pawn to infiltrate the
B file and go for Ruby the rope to b7
but Calvin already has upon and he's not
interested in grabbing another point so
he's always a queen to f8 to protect
this h6 square and prevents any Bishop
h6 ideas so we have rook f2 ff3 one c5
Bishop to g5 preparing Bishop to f6
we have rook a to b8 attacking that B to
pawn and our Bishop to f6 so we have C 4
twin caps Queen to d4 and this is a very
nice centralizing move by the Queen and
also the reason why black didn't capture
this v2 upon because because of this
Queen to d4 move attacking the rook and
b2 and also this pawn on d5
so what white Marin is just to
centralize his queen with a temple on
this d5 pawn as this stops black from
pushing c5 as it has to deal with this
threat of capturing and d5 so we have
Bishop d6 by Kaufman and now Queen C
Queen to a7 attacking this c7 point and
also this a5 pawn coffin plays c5 which
is which is a correct move and now if
white captures an a5 you will simply
capture here on B 2 and this well this
massive pawn island will will be very
dangerous so lien play secrete rope to
see to defending that B to pawn we have
rook rokay
rook to e8 attacking the Queen and
defending the pawn queen to c7 rope to
see it Queen to b6 and now Bishop
captures on f6 we have key captures on
f6 and this is a the critical position
of the game what black does have this
like I said is a very strong pawn Island
and he has this extremely strong passed
pawn that is the pawn on d5 and the
simply playing the d4 here would would
be okay and this would probably end up
being a winning move for black but I
don't know he probably underestimated
the nine-year-old and he was a bit too
sure of his victory and what he plays
Queen to d8 and this was more than
enough for the nine-year-old young to to
take the game as he plays rook captures
on e6 and already you can see this is
well quite troublesome for black the
rook has to be captured the Queen cannot
be captured the rook is not protecting
it and well there is no any move that is
better for black so he does he plays s
captures only six and now Queen captures
an e6 with check we have King to f8 and
also if if the kingdom goes to eight
races and simply nice to e5 or g5
threatening tonight to f7 check so we
have King to f8 and now Knight to g5 and
already you can see that it's a bit
uncomfortable for black here as this
Knight is threatening to capture the
pawn and h7 with checkmate
so Kaplan has had to protect this place
rooks
to a7 protecting that h7 pawn and our
rook to e 2 and well white is better
here but he's not he's not so much
better with precise play this past D
Punk still proved to be very very
dangerous but a couple was probably
already very obsessed about throwing the
game as he was a lot better and he plays
Queen to d7 and this actually allows
amazing for for young we and we have
Knight captures an a7 would check so the
King cannot move only move his Queen
captures an a7 which Coffman plays we
have Queen captures on c8 with check
King to f7 and now White has a forced
checkmate in two moves but Leon good
doesn't go for this it's I don't know
why he probably saw the other win so he
totally disregarded this although it is
pretty simple
Quincy six check and after Kings they
paid simply queen teh checkmate
but after King to have seven he played
the rook to e7 check only move rook
captures I need seven now pawn captures
an e7 and in this position kaufman
resigned as this pawn is preparing to
become a queen and well if the King
captures respond in simply Queen to c7
is picking up his queen and this is all
over
so yeah this is the game and this is
what it looks like when when a
nine-year-old beats the Grandmaster and
Leon go under is actually 14 years old
now and he already has his three
Grandmaster norms and a PD rating of I
think twenty five hundred and forty so
all the conditions are met to achieve
his the Grandmaster title and well I
don't think he received it yet but he
probably will soon and when he does he
will become one of the world's youngest
Grand Master's so also also a nice
record for him
to break as well so this is the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and and yeah it's
been two days since I made my last video
I don't even remember what to say
anymore but yeah you could you can check
to my previous videos here and that's it
yeah thank you for watching guys and I
will see you soon